la décision de quitter le gouvernement
une démission surprise en direct à la
radio qui prend de court tout le monde
même les animateurs aujourd'hui sérieux
oui je suis sérieux nicolas hulot en a
marre d'avaler des couleuvres
marre des tipa du gouvernement français
en matière d'environnement
la planète est en train de devenir une
étude nos ressources naturelles
s'épuisent et ce n'est pas toujours
appréhendé comme un enjeu prioritaire
devenu ministre de la transition
écologique il ya 15 mois
nicolas hulot était une des vedettes
gouvernement deux exercices dans
l'accord de prêt et pour cause l'ancien
animateur de télé des militants
écologistes était l'une des
personnalités préférées des français
une grosse brise d'entreprise dans ma
cran car nicolas hulot avait jusque là
refusé de faire le saut en politique
pour ne pas servir de simple caution
verte au gouvernement son poste de
ministre était pour lui un pari un test
de sa capacité à faire prendre à la
france et à ses dirigeants un véritable
virage écologique mais qu en plein nat
great games mais ceux qui connaissent
nicolas hulot le savez en permanence
déchirée entre ses idéaux et le
pragmatisme imposé par le pouvoir
ça fait des mois et des mois que nicolas
hulot dit sa frustration ça fait deux
mois et des mois qu'il a de plus en plus
de mal à défendre des arbitrages qui l'a
perdu s'ils ont été surpris sur le coup
les membres du gouvernement s'attendait
à cette démission est depuis le danemark
où il se trouve en visite d'état le
président français a défendu son bilan
en matière d'environnement
je pense qu'en quinze mois ce
gouvernement a fait plus qu'aucun autre
dans la même période sur ce sujet et
s'il a vanté son ancien ministre
emmanuel macron n'a pas pu s'empêcher de
critiquer son impatience
c'est un combat qui ne se fait pas du
jour au lendemain il implique de se
confronter au réel il vaut mieux que les
petites phrases
le premier ministre edouard philippe
annoncé qu'il proposerait d'ici quelques
jours une recomposition son gouvernement
un remaniement qui pourrait donc aller
bien au-delà du simple remplacement de
son ministre de l'environnement
une occasion donc peut-être pour
emmanuel macron de redorer un peu son
image lui qui se trouve actuellement au
plus bas dans les sondages
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
paris